[Musique]
en martinique en fait le mal à tête
avait une très mauvaise image au niveau
historique mais ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui était valorisé et s'était même
quelque chose qui était considéré pour
plutôt pour les petites gens et j'ai dû
faire un gros travail au niveau
historique pour le remettre redonner ses
lettres de noblesse
j'ai eu aussi beau pas mal de moqueries
autour du marais tête puisque les gens
beaucoup de gens disent avoir attaché sa
tête mais moi vraiment c'est l'art de
nouer le turban donc il s'agit non pas
de attaché pour le quotidien bien sûr on
peut faire ça et ça je pense que sa
portée de n'importe quelle femme mais
c'est vraiment de le sublimer et de le
mettre vraiment de mettre en avant à
savoir faire une technique et un
raffinement qui va faire que oui en
effet c'est quelque chose de chez nous
mais avec un regard universel
voilà et que toutes les femmes quel que
soit leur origine leur appartenance
peuvent le porter passe quelque chose
qui s'adapte à toutes les femmes du
monde la caraïbe ont à cette richesse
c'est d'être multiculturelle avec
l'afrique
et justement c'était de faire ce mix and
match de le proposer avec un raffinement
disant oui mais aussi un faux caribéen
nous pouvons proposer un esthétisme qui
soit adaptée à toutes les femmes du
monde entier et qui embellissent qui
nous sublime au même titre qu'un chapeau
de luxe voilà c'est un accessoire que je
mets vraiment au niveau du grand chic du
grand luxe parce que le marais texte tel
qu'on le connaît c'est à dire le marais
tête la bamboche qui a été le premier
modèle qui a été porté par les femmes a
franchi puisque à la coiffe
traditionnelle ce sont les femmes qui
avaient un savoir faire qui ont fait
preuve d'ingéniosité et je trouvais ça
dommage que sas dans les placards du
passé le jeu sinon il faut le reprendre
le dépoussiérer et puis montrer ce dont
nous sommes capables nous afro caribéens
[Musique]
lors de cet événement là le marais tête
justement ils ont mis l'accent sur le
marais tête donc c'est dire la place ont
marre et est donc c'est à dire vraiment
qu'on reconnaît qu'en martinique il ya
un savoir faire spécifique à notre
coiffe traditionnelle à notre histoire
du marais tête et sa wii points c'est
une série fierté parce que il ya
quelques années de ça c'est quelque
chose qui était méprisé et aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qu'on nous envie par
mon projet c'est de continuer seulement
proposer des ateliers marais tête parce
que le premier mon premier objectif
c'était de faire que nous antillais nous
puissions remettre le marais tête dans
nos dressings 1 pour le porter au
quotidien avec un jean roch quelque
chose d'actuel et que ce soit pas ce mot
désuet parce que si on veut vraiment que
la tradition continue à traverser les
temps avec nous il faut le moderniser
j'espère oui pouvoir mettre notre marais
tête en haut de la fiche parce que c'est
ce qui rassemble et caribéens c'est le
mari tête c'est l'emblème de tout
caribéen on a tout eu ce réflexe de
s'attacher la tête
on dit bien mari omar était tout un donc
sous forme d'oc et je pense que on a
tout intérêt à valoriser notre savoir
faire que ce soit le maire était tout
autre chose parce que nous avons des
choses à proposer à ce monde